quanti giorni nella
felici io sono felice ogni giorno e ogni
secondo però non è sempre stato così vi
racconto la mia storia
naturalmente non dal big bang ma dal 26
luglio 2006 ero a bordo della mia auto
una distrazione e mi ritrovai
imprigionato all'interno dell'abitacolo
è l'unica cosa che in quel momento e mi
è venuto in mente di fare perché è stato
un po uno shock e prende il telefono e
chiamare mio padre il padre tony e papà
ho avuto un incidente e lui con tutto il
suo cell scontro per modo di dire e mi
fa è grave
io in quel momento lì non sentivo più le
gambe non avevo più sensibilità allora
gli dissi subito si è grave
da quel momento lì un black out totale
non ricordo più nulla
mi ricordo solo dopo qualche ora un via
vai di dottori all'interno dell'ospedale
di rimini e poi dopo successivamente a
al bufalini di cesena per un'operazione
al midollo spinale e da quel momento lì
mi ricordo tante cose tanti flash
ma cosa più importante che la mia
riabilitazione mi parlavano di
montecatone centro di realizzazione ea
imola per mielolesi perché no andiamoci
allora vengo vengo dopo una settimana
vengono trasportato a montecatone da li
capisco veramente che la mia vita era
cambiata nera di quella di prima era era
un full immersion nel senso che i due
ragazzi in carrozzina destra a sinistra
e mi chiedevo ma proprio a me 2 a
capitare proprio a me questa cosa
allora la rido ma non è proprio così
e niente dopo
[Applauso]
dopo una settimana circa dal mio
atteggiamento montecatone e i dottori
insieme a mio padre tony e mia madre
stella mi dicono che non potevo più
camminare come un po criminale prima
giocavo a calcio giocavo lavorava nel
bar di famiglia insomma mi divertivo
come tanti altri
anzi sapevo come divertirmi parola più
giusta niente da quel momento lì da
quella da quel discorso fatto in camera
il quel giorno ho perso 20 chili 22 kg
in 20 giorni mi guardavo allo specchio e
non mi vedevo più se non ero più mirko
ero semplicemente miei muscoli erano
come scesi come cola colavano come neve
al sole ecco propri giusto non ero più
mirko una bega e niente il ventunesimo
giorno non so cosa sia stato in quel in
quel momento in quel click mi è scattato
in testa
feci una domanda davanti allo specchio
mi dissi mirko vuoi morire davvero in
risposta era assolutamente no
da quel momento lì la mia vita visto che
parliamo di resilienza in un qualche
modo è ripartita è ripartita e dopo un
buon caffè naturalmente fatto con amore
sono partito carico come una molla
perché volevo spaccare il mondo
ripresi a mangiare e dopo
dopo settimane continua a guardare allo
specchio iniziamo a vedere finalmente
mirko che mi piaceva un mirko che non
qualche modo rispecchiava quello di
prima
però la strada è ancora lunga e il mio
unico obiettivo
qual'era era tornare a camminare ma
soprattutto era vedere negli occhi dei
miei genitori la voglia di poter
camminare io c'ho messo di tutto di più
di più di più e di più ecco bravo e farà
ancora come vedete sono ancora qua su
una sedia su quattro ruote che a volte
impegno anche ma la cosa più bella è che
è non mollerò mai nella mia vita non
mollerò mai
[Applauso]
mi ributto nella mia coriano ritorno a
coriano nella mia amata coriano e mi
innamoro dello sport un muro del termine
da tavolo uno sport come tanti ma per me
era uno sport che sport del tennis
tablet però fondamentalmente era uno
sport anche questo è niente nel giro di
qualche di un anno dopo tanto sudore
tanta fatica ma soprattutto tanta tanta
voglia di vincere perché la mia vita si
usa tra vincere e cosa faccio vengo
convocato ai campionati parolin piziali
non sarebbe d'oro e lì e vinco la
medaglia di bronzo di bronzo ragazze
bronzo
sinceramente non ci credevo poi la cosa
più bella è era così era era quella
medaglia al collo
pesava tanto ma tanto ma la cosa più
bella era quando mi giravo e di piacere
la bandiera dell'italia e e poi l'inno
di mameli che suonava per me
ciao li avevo già vinto
[Applauso]
cosa faccio mi mirin vento di nuovo
vengo coinvolto da un gruppo di amici a
alla cartella reso un evento qua a
coriano che coinvolti coinvolge 10 mila
persone vi spiego cos'è la cartella race
è un dei mezzi senza motore che molto
creativi che in poche parole per farla
breve ci si butta giù in discesa e ci si
diverte come dei pazzi ecco e acori a
coriano portano oltre 10 mila persone da
dal nord al sud
insomma tutta l'italia diversi team
tutta l'italia ma dopo questo flusso di
persone vengono coinvolti anche diversi
piloti della motogp tra cui marco
simoncelli
nicolò bulega alex de angelis mattia
pasini marco bisacchi mi soffermo un
attimo perché fondamentalmente su marco
simoncelli cui siamo nella nostra nella
sua casa nel suo museo è
fondamentalmente quel giorno a coriano
lasciato tanto il 23 settembre perché
dopo un mese e lui non c'è stato più
profondamente io lo voglio ricordare col
sorriso perché tutti vanno a dove marco
io marchio ce l'ho qui nel cuore
non ricordo qui perché a me mirko ma non
credo non penso solo a mirko ma tante
altre persone ha lasciato tanto e il suo
sorriso ma lo voglio ricordare così
[Applauso]
poi mi piace sognare e ultimamente tanto
nel 2015 per pepe per promuovere la card
in da ridere per manuela karate larese
faccio una chiamata chiamo il mio
sindaco di corea attuale mi ma spinelli
poi chiamò don stefano che qui è
presente e dico ma ce la siamo col
paracadute e loro dicono
certo come no io sono rimasto un po così
insomma un sindaco donna un don e un
disabile
[Applauso]
io non me la sto a raccontare perché
certe emozioni bisogna viverle e questa
è una di quelle che consiglio tutti
perché fondamentalmente è una cosa ciao
il quale sarebbe sparito non c'era più
una bomba ad adrenalina così era te non
mi è mai capitato con quello consiglio
tutti voi cosa succede succede che dopo
dopo tre anni di tante dure battaglie
brega da fine nasce riviera basket
la prima squadra di basket in carrozzina
e la romagna
ma la cosa più bella è che siamo proprio
un gruppo di amici e poi nasce nasce
perché fondamentalmente cerchiamo di
diffondere non solo perché noi siamo in
carrozzina
il gesto perché fondamenta del nostro
gesto a tirare canestro e come quello
dei normodotati e identico non cambia
nulla semplicemente non venite a vedere
le carrozzine perché siamo no di credere
noi che giochiamo basket è questo cosa
dico dico che abbiamo un sogno no
abbiamo un sogno
noi del riviera basket e in qualche modo
torna indietro faccio un passaggio
perché non mi voglio dimenticare di
questo passaggio quest'anno abbiamo
partecipato al campionato di serie b
abbiamo vinto tre partite e mi ricordo
una partita importante a trento la
vittoria 30 30 è stato ho potuto tanto
comunque ho creduto tanto la mia
carrozzina si alzava da basket così da
quanto godevo però per me è stata
un'emozione indimenticabile
e questa è la mia squadra di basket ma
il nostro sogno quale è creare un
settore giovanile per ragazzi per
ragazzi con disabilità perché noi se
giochiamo basket ha una certa età con un
po vecchietto ecco cerco di di mettere
su in poche parole una squadra dove
possiamo dare un futuro ma poi saputo
un'altra cosa io insieme i miei ragazzi
ci piacerebbe un sogno un giorno visto
che ci piace sognare arrivare anche in
serie a perché no
mi soffermo su una cosa in giro quando
capito male nei bar
io sorrido sempre allora volte mi mi
dicono ma sei matto cosa che hai io
sinceramente sono contento questo sono
molto fortunato molto fortunato perché
ho avuto la fortuna o sfortuna io mi
reputo fortunato ho avuto la fortuna di
cosa dire scavare dentro di me dentro
mirko perché non tutti ce la posso ce la
possiamo fare io ho avuto questa fortuna
qui sono fortunato scavato dentro di me
e ho trovato la resilienza perché mi
piace sognare
mi piace tanto sognare e il mio prossimo
sogno
no il prossimo mi piace di più a cui
tengo di più e contagiare tutti voi
perché fondamentalmente noi siamo noi
voi siete il nostro futuro
voi qual è il vostro sogno
[Applauso]